on the mound a right-hander
airmon marquez am i kidding 296
16 home runs he'll hit this one out
toward left center field that'll get
down for a base hit
turning and stopping at second is walsh
it's not unusual for trout to get a base
hit in this ballpark
chow now a career 500 hitter at coors
field with that base hit 15 for 30.
anthony rendell with one out has a
couple of men on
that's hit to the left side trevor story
to the backhand bobbles it has no play
throws it away
coming into scores walsh the angels will
have a one-nothing lead
that's one of those as soon as the ball
got away from story he really had no
play because trav was all over the bag
at second so the batter now is justin
upton
opted swinging first pitch bounces one
to the left side and that is through
base hit
two-nothing angels as trout scores that
baseball skipped by ornato as well
mentioned that ground is still wet
griffin
this will be his ninth start oh and
three nol narnado
third baseman 269. arnotto sky's one
now towards shadow left center field
trout has to come racing in
underneath it and the inning is number
three and four coming up for the halos
here in the third walsh
scored one of the two runs as he rolls
this one down line nice play by fuentes
he'll race to the back it just did beat
walsh
for the first down the point is some
quick hands what a play that was
so rendone to work against marquez
trendone this should be a 643 it is
so a nice job by story one out for
trevor story
runners in scoring position here's the
3-2
and this ball in the air deep right
center field and it
is not handled by trout
here comes fuentes to the plate tony the
third two to one
on the double by trevor storey
seemed to be a miscommunication out in
right center between
trout and taylor ward rockies
great opportunity now to take the lead
second and third one out
three on the right side for blackman and
this ball just deep center field tony's
got to get back and
tag he does he'll score the time run on
the south fly
by charlie also moving from second to
third his story
larr is on with the lead off singles
matt
kemp is the batter and it's the ground
ball left side simmons the red heapo
on the first double play two down it's
the third double play
turned behind first base runner
by way of the walk for los angeles
walsh with top spin to mcmahon that was
a risky play
safe that was not the right play get the
out
i understand what mac's thinking there
but just get the out
and trouble with mike trout at the plate
who was singled
twice tonight and trout with a line
drive to right
charlie makes a sliding catch boy off
the bat
because the outfield naturally is very
deep you're thinking that's going to
drop in front of charlie
very fine catch by blackman two outs i
like tapia to run early in this count
well we'll never know this ball's hit to
deep right field get up
get up get up get up and it hits the
wall
pops way up in the air and ward can't
find it toppy is scored
trevor to third with a triple in the
rockies lead three to two
there's a little ledge out there okay so
he thought oh i've got that
and he ends up running out of real
estate he got too close to that wall
so story with a triple his second ribby
of the game and the rockies have their
first lead
it'll be justin upton a single to
driving a run in the first here's the
3-2
oh yeah that was well off the plate
here is shohei ohtani did he go too far
he did and that's strike three
chris guccione down at third base the
crew chief
said he chased that breaking ball back
to back strikeouts for marcus
michael gibbons acquired from the
baltimore orioles
end of august takes over here jared
walsh the first batter
then his sky down toward right center
field taking blackman back near the wall
that is gone
big fly for jared walsh and we are tied
at three
those hands were located now really
comfortable in the batter's box and get
through the baseball hits that fastball
out immediately ties the game up
so the go-ahead run aboard for nolan
high fly ball deep left field
and this one is caught at the wall
charlie returns to first nolan
flirted with a go-ahead two-run homer
ward got back and caught it up against
the wall
boom will be the next batter that is
pulled out to right field hit
well down the line that is gone big fly
for anthony bemboom and the angels have
a 4-3 lead
boom with a blast ryan mcmahon
hole for three tonight man drives it to
left field
ward going back and it is gone
just got over the barrier touch them all
time for ryan mcmahon an opposite field
homer that
he and his ball club really needed
we're tied at four here we go bottom of
the knife bases loaded
high fly ball deep right center field
and this one is a walk off grand
slam that'll work as well
second slam in the last couple of weeks
for blackman
how gratifying is that 8-4
colorado